Would you excuse me a moment I have a
phone call to make and I left my phone in here
It's a number that I've been
calling quite a bit recently so it's
programmed into the phone
[PHONE RINGS]
Find the phone under your seat there
that's ringing
Okay
Would you like to
press the orange button please
If you take the call and then use it as an
ordinary phone
Hold it up to your ear
Hello? Can you hear me on the phone?
Quite clearly
Good. Can you tell me your name please?
Maxwell Charles Lovell Hoare
Hello Maxwell. Have you ever used a cell
phone before?
No
Well, they're really rather
fun things
What I'd like to do is to
read you a couple of lines of poetry
little bit at a time and ask you to read
it back to me
Okay? You understand?
Here we go then "The mountain and the squirrel"
The mountain and the squirrel
"had a quarrel"
had a quarrel
"and the former called the latter"
and the former called the latter
"little prig"
little prig
Thank you very much
I'll tell you why I asked you to do that
because there was once a very historic
demonstration of one of the very
earliest telephones that was made from
this desk at the RI and the words used
by Professor Tyndall, who operated it
that day, included that poem.
He had it read back from the other end of the
telephone and I thought it'd be rather
nice to reenact that over the phone
Now if you have another look at the control board
on the phone you'll see just below
the orange dial there's one marked "End"
Okay?
So say goodbye first
Bye-bye
Bye-bye then.
If you press the button now that'll
disconnect the call thank you for
helping!
[APPLAUSE]